What's your problem-
Holly of the Mizumoto syndicate?
I'm Gena of UN's CTAC.
I need you to cooperate.
CTAC? What do you want with me?
You were talking
with the Tanaseda syndicate.
They're under strict CTAC surveillance.
I learned about you
from that communication.
Thought we wouldn't know?
How careless of you.
As are you.
I'm her babysitter.
Come over here.
Are you a Mizumoto yakuza?
There's no bigger scum
than gangsters who use children.
Requesting backup!
Second platoon, come in--
Get behind me.
Are they with you?
What do you think?
Help...
A "real death"...
His digital consciousness
won't be retrievable.
His sleeve... it's enhanced for combat.